alright welcome to the course my name is
John elder from Cody Macau and I'll be
your instructor today in this video I
want to spend just a couple of minutes
sort of touching base talking a little
bit about what to expect from the course
talking about some of the tools that
we're gonna need and letting you know
how to get in contact with me if you
have any questions along the way but
before we get started if you like this
video want to see more like if you sure
to smash the like button below subscribe
to that channel give me a thumbs up for
the YouTube algorithm and check out my
website Cody me comm where I've dozens
of courses with hundreds of videos that
teach you to code use coupon code camp
to get 65% off membership that's all my
courses videos and books for one-time
fee it just $27 which is insanely cheap
so right off the bat I'm on a Windows
computer hopefully you are too if you're
on Mac or Linux though no big deal
whatsoever you can definitely follow
along all the tools and things that
we're gonna use in this course have a
Mac or Linux equivalent and there
shouldn't be any real changes at all
between what I'm doing here and what
you'll do on your Mac or Linux the code
is gonna be the exact same there's no
changes that need to be made or anything
like that it should work just fine so
speaking of the tools that we're gonna
need we're gonna need obviously Python
now sequel light actually comes with
Python so there's nothing else to
download besides Python it will also
need some sort of text editor to write
our code on now I'm going to use
something called sublime text if you
have some other text editor that you
like using pycharm Visual Studio code
anything at all notepad plus plus
absolutely feel free to use that if
you're comfortable using that if you
know how to use that if you know if you
like using a particular one over another
one absolutely feel free to do that no
big deal whatsoever we also need some
sort of terminal to write our commands
on now windows computers come with
several terminals there's the command
prompt
there's PowerShell now those aren't that
great so I'm going to download something
else something called the git bash
terminals completely free sublime text
is free too as well as Python so nothing
to buy in order to watch this course and
but like I said git bash works great so
we're gonna use that if you're on Mac or
Linux you could just use the terminal
that comes with Mac or Linux just got a
little search function type in terminal
and you should be fine you can't
absolutely download the get bash
terminal on Mac or Linux if you want to
follow along exactly but it's definitely
not necessary so that's really all the
tools we're going to need in order to
take this course like I said not much to
see qualité as
our tools and stuff since it just comes
with Python so that's really cool so
finally I want to talk about how to get
me contact me if you have questions so
I'm in Las Vegas which is Pacific West
Coast time in the US so if you're on the
other side of the world and it's during
the day I'm probably sleeping back in
Vegas so just sort of keep that in mind
when you sort of factor in a response
time but absolutely feel free to ask
questions along the way if you don't
understand something if your codes not
working correctly if you just don't
quite get something that I'm saying and
you need some clarifications shoot me a
message that's what I'm here for I do
this full-time this is my job
so I'm either creating courses or
answering questions for students and so
that's cool you can get in contact with
me on my website Kota be calm there's a
contact form and just click on it it
shoots straight to my email so I'll see
that as soon as I you know as soon as my
email dings and I can see it you can
also obviously post a comment below this
video if you're watching this on YouTube
or wherever and that will work just fine
too so there are no stupid questions if
you know if you want to ask a question
on something else I'm not as receptive
but absolutely anything in this course
anything in these videos you don't quite
understand or like I said if your code
isn't working if you're getting errors
or something shoot me a message we'll
get to the bottom of it and that's cool
alright first things first we need
Python so chances are you might already
have Python on your computer even if you
do I recommend you uninstall it
reinstall it and download it again and
reinstall it and I'll show you why in
just a second so to do that we're gonna
head over to Python org you can google
it if you want or just type in Python
org and come to downloads and you can
see right here it says Python three
point seven point three that's the most
current version right now if that
version has changed by the time you
watch this video as long as it's not
version four anything below four go
ahead and download whatever version it
is perfectly fine so go ahead and click
this button and we want to save this
anywhere I'm just gonna save it on my
desktop and it's not a very big file in
fact it's boom it are downloaded and so
go ahead and click it to install this
thing and we want to run it
just clicked it a couple of times there
okay so instead
Python 3.72 32bit now this is the first
thing there is a 64-bit version the
32-bit version is actually the one that
you want it's the most common one it
works perfectly fine on 64-bit computers
we all have a 64-bit computer so don't
try and go find the 64-bit you can
download the 64-bit version from the
website I don't recommend that you do
that it's just a hassle there's no real
benefit to doing that so this is the one
we want
now before we click this button this is
the most important thing right here and
it is so very important and this is why
I recommend that you download this and
reinstall it
even if python is already on your
computer and that's this little check
box right here add python 3.7 to path
and on a Windows computer path means you
can run Python in this case anywhere on
your computer right you don't have to be
in the Python directory in order to run
Python if you don't check this box you
have to be in the Python directory in
order to run Python you can't just run
it from anywhere so we want to be able
to run it from anywhere right so go
ahead and click that box make sure
there's a little checkbox the check mark
is is selected on there and it's so
weird that by default this is not
selected we absolutely want this checked
and if you install Python some other
time chances are you didn't click that
little box because it's not the default
you're not paying attention whoever
reads the stuff on the installation
screen you just click Next right so
there's a good chance that you don't
have Python installed on your path and
we want to make sure that it is so go
ahead and check that once you do that go
ahead and click install now and I'm
gonna click no and cancel this thing
because I've already installed Python
but you'll click OK and just wait for
the installation process to complete
it'll scroll through some stuff there'll
be a little bar status bar and then
that'll be that and you're good to go
now in order to use Python we don't have
to launch Python we don't have to start
it we don't have to do anything at all
we've added it to our path now we can
just use it anytime we want anywhere we
want always on our computer so very cool
if you're on a Mac I don't have
instructions for you to install on a Mac
you can just go to youtube and type in
Python installation Mac and it'll see a
little two-minute video
I'll show you if you don't already know
yourself chances are you already do so
we'll just leave it at that so that's
all for this video in the next video
we'll jump in and look at installing our
text editor and our command prompt
terminal
okay so we've installed Python now we
want to install the text editor that
we're gonna use throughout this course
and I am just using this it's the
sublime text editor we'll take a look at
it more detail in just a minute but it's
sort of like the standard text editor
most coders use it it's super easy to
use has all the bells and whistles that
you would want and it's completely free
now you can actually pay a little box
will pop up every once in a while asking
for a donation so if you want to throw
those guys some money that's cool you
absolutely don't have to you can use it
forever for free just whenever that box
pops up every few weeks or so just click
no and and that's that so to use this
thing I'm just gonna go to google and
type in sublime text and the first thing
that popped up is sublime text calm or
you could just go directly there and
here's the website all you have to do is
click download for Windows right now
it's sublime text 3 build 3 207 if it's
a different number by the time you watch
this video no big deal whatsoever just
download the latest version now I'm not
going to install this because there's
nothing to it
just like in the last video with the
Python the little thing will pop up down
here you click it and just walk through
the installation wizard I don't think
there's anything you actually have to do
I just click all the defaults ok and
then install it and after you've
installed it you can run it by going to
your Windows Start menu and just typing
in sublime and little icon will pop up
and you can click it so that's cool now
the last thing we need and the only
other thing we need is a terminal
something to run commands on and it
really doesn't matter what kind of
terminal you use if you're on Linux or
Mac they come with a terminal that's
perfectly fine you can use that on a Mac
just go up the little search thing of
the type at the top and type in terminal
and it'll pop up you know if you're on
Windows there's a command prompt or a
PowerShell you can probably use either
of those I don't like using those I
enjoy instead using the Python or using
the git bash terminal allows us to do
version control we're not going to do
any version control in this course
because there's not much to it
code wise but if you've got a big
project and you want to use git or
github you need something that'll
for that and this gate Bosch terminal
does so it's really nice and it's
absolutely free so use that I'm just
gonna go to Google Google and type and
get Bosch that should be it and then
here's the website git - SCM com4 slash
downloads and so we can click download
this and I will walk you through this
one because it's a little weird so I'm
just going to download this to the
desktop and it takes a little bit longer
for this to download it's only 44
megabytes and so it should download
immediately especially on a high-speed
Internet like I have for some reason it
takes a bit to download it always has
it's something about this website or
something it's just it's on a slow
server or something and here we go it's
downloaded so go ahead and click that
and run it let me pull this over and so
okay it's just the license click Next
and you can leave all of these the
defaults now here it's saying what text
editor would you like to use now this is
weird because we're not going to use
this in a text editor you don't use it
it's a standalone thing right so we are
gonna use sublime text so I'll just
leave this but you can just ignore this
if you want just click Next and here we
want to use git and optionally unix
tools from the command prompt we're
gonna like I said we're also we're gonna
use the git bash terminal on its own so
this again doesn't really matter but
we'll leave this one clicked here at the
bottom and click Next OpenSSH this is
for pushing stuff up to like github
where you need an SSH key we're not
gonna use any of this doesn't matter we
just click Next same for this click Next
and this is well this is a get thing
we're not gonna be using get really in
this course so we can click Next again
same thing with this min TTY thing next
basically were just taking all of the
defaults again click Next
you get to this final thing and then go
ahead and click install now I'm not
going to do that because I've already
installed it so I'll just click cancel
but you can click install am I sure you
say em and it takes a couple of minutes
to install it has a little you know
statusbar thing that'll scroll through
and finish when it's finished and yeah
that's all there is to it so those are
all the tools we need we don't have to
download anything else in order to using
this so in the next video we'll jump
right in and start writing some code and
using the database
all right so we've got all the tools we
need all the things we have to download
and install now we can just start using
this database so most people don't
realize sequel Lite 3 comes with Python
it's built in already so there's nothing
to download there's nothing to install
it's already there all you have to do is
just sort of reference it in your code
and start using it so in order to use
sequel I three all we have to do is
import and then name it so it's SQL ite
3 right so this is just a blank file
that we've opened in sublime first thing
we want to do is save this and we need
to save this as a Python file so I'm
look at my pair to file and save as and
go to our C directory here and we need
to create a new directory in order to
hold all the files that we're going to
be creating throughout this course so
I'm just going to right click and click
new folder and let's just name this
sequel Lite so then we can click on here
and we can name this anything we want
let's name it sequel Lite PI well no we
don't want to name it the same thing
that we import here and then the sequel
Lite 3 so you go let's just call this a
database dot PI and you see as soon as
we do that things sort of change color a
little bit
this becomes red that tells us that
sublime now knows that this is a Python
program a Python file that we've created
right so that's cool so all right now
we've imported sequel i3 the next step
is to create a connection and in order
to do anything we need a connection to
our database so we need a way for this
file to sort of connect and do stuff so
to do that's really easy we just create
a variable you can call it anything you
want but I'm just going to call this con
short for connection and then we want to
send set this equal to sequel I'd 3 dot
connect and then we want to pass in the
name of the
database that we want to create now this
will connect to whatever we call the
database and if it doesn't exist it will
create it in this directory in this
sequel Lite directory that we just we
just create it so we can call this
anything we want let's just call it
customer dot DB we're gonna pretend we
have a company we have customers so
we're gonna create a database of those
customers so that's pretty much all we
need to do and one thing I will note
sequel Lite 3 allows you to create a
database like we've just done or you
could also just use a database in memory
and
it won't save it you can use it in your
program but then as soon as the program
ends the database disappears so you can
do stuff to it but it's not permanent
right so if you want to do that I'm just
gonna copy this and paste instead of
naming the database oops
but instead of naming this database
instead we just type in colon go on
colon and then memory and then another
colon right so this will create a
connection to a database in memory now
what we're not going to do that in this
course we want to actually save our
database that we can use it later on if
we want to but if you've just got some
little thing you need to store some data
do some stuff too and then delete it
afterwards
this memory thing will work so that's
kind of cool I'll just comment that out
okay so we've got our connection and if
we save this I'm gonna hit ctrl s on my
keyboard now we can run this it won't
actually do much well that's not
actually true to run this head over to
your Windows Start menu and type in get
bash right just search for get bash and
that will open up this and if we go PWD
we can see we're in the C users flat
planet directory now my computer is
called flat planet it's just the name of
it I don't think the world is flat I
just find it hilarious that some people
do so that's when I named my computer
whatever your computer name is or
whatever your user name is you'll likely
see that there so what we want to do
first off is change directories we want
to move into that directory we just
created with our sublime text so to do
that we use the CD command stands for
change directory and then just type in C
and then sequel Lite I think that's the
name of the directory we just created
with sublime and if we type in LS we can
see our database PI file that we've just
created and that is just this file right
here all right database dot PI and
there's not much going on in here just
yet but we can still run this and to run
it as long as we're in this directory we
just type in Python and then the name of
the file which is database
and if we do that it doesn't look like
anything's happen but now if we type in
LS we see this customer dot DB file it's
been created and that is just this guy
right here so the database wasn't wasn't
there before but when we ran this
connection it noticed that there wasn't
a there wasn't a database called
customary DB and we're trying to connect
to customer DB so it just creates it for
us so that's a real quick and easy way
to create a database and that's all for
this video in the next video we'll
create a table and then we'll start
adding data to that table and should be
fun
all right so we've created our database
we have a connection now we want to
build a table in order to you know put
data in and if you're not really
familiar with databases a database
itself doesn't really do much it's the
table inside that has all the stuff in
it all the data goes into the table
whenever you query a database you're
querying a table whenever you're putting
information into a database you're
putting it into a table so it's the
table that's the important thing of a
database and think of a table as an
Excel spreadsheet it's just a big thing
with rows and columns right that's
pretty much it so if you can visualize a
spreadsheet that's what a table is and
so to create a table in sequel a3 it's
pretty simple first we need to create a
cursor and a cursor is it's sort of like
I don't know it's it's it's what tells
the database what you want to do so
whenever you do anything you're going to
use your cursor to do it and you'll
understand more exactly what that means
as we start to use this it's really easy
we just have to build it once and then
we can use it so to create a cursor we
just create a variable and you can call
it anything you want you could call it
cursor if you wanted I'm just gonna call
it C because we're gonna be typing it a
lot so just C so C equals and we want to
connect to our connection this con and
then we want to create a cursor instance
and you don't need to know what that
means it's just it's the cursor right so
we do that and let's make a comment and
I'm gonna go create a cursor okay so now
we can use this cursor to do all kinds
of things and the first thing we want to
do is create a table so let's go create
a table now so to create a table it's
really easy we use our cursor C and
whenever we're we want to do things in
the database we're almost always
executing some command so we want to go
C dot execute and then pass in whatever
commands we want
this case we're gonna create a table and
there's a couple of different ways to
execute commands using sequel and the
first one I'm going to show you is
something called a docstring
I think this was yeah doc string and
it's just six quotation marks right and
inside of here you can do multiple
things on multiple lines right that's
why we want to use this doc string and
this is what the Python documentation
recommends you do now a lot of times
when we execute a command to our
database we're just doing one thing
right add Bob to the database right so
that's one line we won't use doc strings
we'll just use regular quotation marks
but in this instance when we're creating
a whole table there's gonna be a lot of
data to push up we want to do it on
multiple lines just so it's easier to
read and so we'll use these doc strings
so what we want to do is create a table
and what do we want to call our table or
our database is a customer database so
let's create a table of customers plural
so the customers table is in the
customer singular database call it
anything you want though it doesn't
really matter and now all we have to do
now is define the rows and columns that
we want so this is gonna be on several
lines I'm just gonna tab over here so
what do we want well we want to record
customers first names their last names
and let's say a email so we just sort of
put all those things out we've been
first and what we want to call it first
underscore name and then we have to
decide the data type I'll just put the
data type for now and we'll talk about
data types in a minute so first name
last underscore name data type and email
or email address let's just do email and
then data type okay
now we can yes and let's have these over
again okay
so I'll talk about data types in just a
second but let's look at this here we're
creating a table and one thing I should
note sequel like three is case-sensitive
so the things you type capitalized or
lowercase they matter so this needs to
be capital create table and then
lowercase customers okay so let's look
at this whole command if I copy this and
print it again just to give you an
example without the doc strings we could
just use regular quotation marks but you
see you get these big red angry error
messages here in our sublime text that's
because this all needs to go on one line
if you use single quotation marks
and let's see finally boom so okay this
will work right this is equally valid
this is valid and this is valid but just
look at this right here like it's hard
to read this right you know you got a
scroll you know it's all smooshed
together it's just no good that's why I
use these
doc string triple quotation marks in
this case so just a quick little aside
so alright we're almost there now we
need to talk about datatypes and
datatypes if you're familiar with
programming a data type is a type of
data so like think strings numbers
integers boolean's Python has a bunch of
other data types like lists and
dictionaries and things like that if
you're familiar with data types it's the
same thing here you have to define the
type of data that's going to be in each
of these fields so in our case first
name last name and email those are all
text type things so we need a take that
we need to define a text data type now
the thing about sequel lights is
actually kind of cool I actually like is
it only has five data types that you can
choose from other databases my sequel
Postgres any other database you can
think of has dozens of data types and it
can get confusing because you only
really use a couple right if you think
about it you're going to use text you're
going to use numbers that's probably
about it right so that's kind of cool
that sequel I three only has five and
the five are null let's see an integer
I'll talk about these in just a second
here
a real text and blob right so
Knowle just means does it exist or does
it not exist if it doesn't exist it's
not right if it does exist it's not an
all right an integer is a number a whole
number 1 9 106 2 million right as
opposed to real which is a decimal 10.5
right 1995 that's real right so if
you're using something as a number just
use integer if you have decimals use
real text is just how it sounds to text
and finally blob is it's it's it's
extraordinary file music file might be a
blob right it's just a blob right so
pretty simple in our case we're gonna
use text for all of these so we just
type in text text and text and that's it
all right let's go
data types right okay so we're almost
there now there's one more step actually
two more steps we need to do we've
created this cursor right and now we've
created a command for the cursor to do
but our program hasn't actually executed
that cursor command yet right in order
to do that we need to commit this thing
to the database and if you're familiar
with other databases committing
something to a database as a common
theme here to do it we just commit our
connection so Khan dot commit right and
that's it
this will now execute this guy right
here push whatever we're trying to do
into the database and do whatever we're
trying to do finally the last thing we
really need to do and let's go commit
our command the last thing we need to do
is close our connection so anytime you
create a connection like we did up here
right you want to close that connection
you don't have to when your file stops
running it will by default close itself
but it's just best practice to do it
explicitly and to do that we just type
in conn dot close all right okay so if
we save this and now run it pull up our
terminal clear the screen and I'm just
gonna push up on my keyboard and that
will scroll to previous commands and we
just type in Python database dot pi
which is the name of our file and we hit
this boom nothing has happened on the
screen but we didn't get any error
messages so that means that this thing
executed correctly we've now created a
table called customers inside of that
customers table there are three columns
first name last name and email and now
we can start sending data into the
database and we'll look at how to do
that in the next video
okay so we've got our table created now
we want to put data into the table so
how do we do that well pretty simple we
just create another cursor command right
so seed execute anytime we do anything
we want to execute our see our cursor
right and so now we want to insert data
into our table so we use the insert into
sequel command and this is all just
sequel if you're familiar with sequel
sequel these are just sequel commands
right very basic so they're always
capitalized like that so we're we want
to insert into customers the name of our
table and then values and then just
type in whatever values we want so
remember we have first name last name
and email so we need three things right
so we want let's go John
and we separate each of these by comma
elder comma and then John at Kota me.com
right so you notice I'm using single
quotes that's because we started this
string off with a double quote so if we
used if we try to use a double quote
here the whole thing would be wonky
because it would think that we're trying
to close this double quote instead we
just use single quotes and everything
works fine so let's see that worked that
looks good now again we need to commit
this command so we'll just leave that
there and we need to close our
connection so let's go ahead and save
this come back here and run this again
and again we get no message now we could
create a little message if we wanted to
you know we could just print to the
screen command executed successfully I
don't know you know if we wanted to do
that we could we definitely don't have
to do that so we've now inserted one
record one row into our database we can
do more than that we could go Tim M
Smith let's go Tim at Kota me calm so if
we save this come back here run it again
command executed successfully it makes
you feel a little better that something
is on the screen right whatever let's do
one more let's go Mary what's a good
last name Mary Brown I don't know and
she's at Mary echo to me calm save this
run it again okay so now we've got three
records in our database pretty simple to
sort of add one thing at a time to our
database and it's all for this video
okay the last video we inserted one
value at a time and sometimes you want
to do that but sometimes you want to
sort of insert lots of things all at
once how do you do that well it's a
little bit more complicated but not too
much more complicated so let's create I
don't know many customers a variable and
we want this to be a Python list right
so inside of here each item as you would
with any Python item you can go like
this right so each of these things
become an item right so let's say like a
couple inside of a list right and here
you would just go let's go Wes at Brown
and let's go Wes at Brown comm right and
we can put these on multiple lines if we
want to sort of just make it easier to
read we can go I don't know
staff and staff at and
we can go an pass and Dan's email
address is Dan at Escom all right I'm
going to go ahead and put
there at the end of that okay so now we
need to do a little bit different down
here in our execute instead of executing
we're going to execute many right
slightly different command there and
here instead of typing in all the things
we want to create a tuple and we want to
put placeholders so the placeholder in
sequel i3 is the question mark
so - a question mark question mark
question mark so this is sort of first
name last name email right and then we
put a comma and we just pass in the name
of our list here right any customer
actually this changes many customers
makes more sense right okay so what's
going to do here is it's going to
execute many each of these is one two
three and here's the placeholder for
each one
well pretty simple if we save this and
run it again command execute a
successful
so hopefully that has worked we don't
know yet if any of these have worked
because we haven't actually looked
inside of our database to see what's in
there and we'll do that in the next
video
okay so we've put a bunch of stuff into
the database now how do we get anything
out and sort of display it see what's in
there well to do that we need to query
the database and to do that we use our
cursor see that executes there you go
and then inside of here we want to
select and let's just pull out
everything at this point so star stands
for everything from and we want to pull
it out from the customers table all
right so that sort of creates the query
and to actually get the thing we need to
then go see dot fetch and you can do
three different things I'll just type
them out we can fetch one we can see dot
fetch many and then pass in how many
ever many we want or we can see dot
fetch all and this will return as you
would expect everything this will just
fetch the left the last item in the
table yeah so what we want to do is
fetch all so if we run this nothing
actually happens we have to actually
print to the screen explicitly so we
would wrap this whole thing in a print
function and then we can go ahead and
comment out that so let's save this and
run it and see what we got here and boom
we get all of this stuff and this is
returned as a Python list right so here
we have John elder that was the first
one Tim Smith Mary Brown and then that
time in the last video when we did them
all at once we had Wes Steph and Dan and
you can see all of them are sort of
just sort of spewing up on the screen
right so this is just all the data given
at once obviously you can do all kinds
of stuff to pull out specific stuff to
make this look more pretty readable
pretty you know useful and I think we'll
look at that in the next video
okay so we fetched all right right off
the bat it spewed back all this stuff we
can also let's go ahead and comment this
out and we could just fetch one and if
we want to print this to the screen we
wrap it all on print function we save
this and run it just real quick just to
show you what this other stuff does boom
John elder John Academy comm you can see
it looks like a tuple couple however you
want to say that and you can access it
just as a tupple so you notice this is
the very first thing so it's not the
last thing it fetch one brings you it's
the first thing right likewise you could
do let's see
fetch mini let's comment this out and we
want to wrap this save this and run it
we get three one two and three it's just
the first second and third one right so
kind of interesting but we don't want to
do that we want to work with fetch all
and now we want to do stuff right so
well actually first before we do that
let's go back to the fetch one now this
is a tupple so we can access the stuff
inside of it by referencing the the item
number so first off before we do that
let's just save this and run it again
just to show you real quick I'm gonna
clear the screen
okay so fetch one brings one record John
elder and Johnny code me calm so this is
the zero with item in the tupple this is
the first item and this is the second
item this is just python tuples stuff
you're familiar with tuples or lists
when you number items in a list or a
tuple the first one is 0 the second one
is 1 and the third one is 2 right so we
can access specific ones of those by
referencing those numbers and to do that
we just I said slap on the brackets here
and let's just call 0 the 0 with item
that should be John so if you save this
and run it boom we hit John so that is
one way to do it right
and you can do the same thing with fetch
fetch all and fetch many for that matter
but that's not really what we want to
look at right now we want to look at is
fetch all and this is a list right so we
could set a new variable we could create
a variable called items and set it equal
to this then we could either just print
items in fact if we do this it'll look
the same save this and run it as it did
earlier just spews out all of it right
or you could create a loop of some sort
to loop through each thing let's go
ahead and give that a try so let's go
for item in items print item okay so if
we save this and run it just a basic for
loop boom we have each of these printed
out one line at a time now we're
starting to get somewhere it's starting
to be a little bit more readable right
so each of these are now a tupple and we
can do couple e things to them so
instead of printing out the whole item
we could print out use our brackets and
say print out the zeroeth item inside
each tuple so if we save this and run it
we get john timm mary wes staff and dan
very cool there are three columns so we
could if we really wanted to play around
with this we could go print this plus we
can then concatenate and let's make a
space and concatenate again and let's go
item 1 concatenate make another space
and then concatenate it again and go
item
- right so if we save this and run it
now let's clear the screen we get John
elder John at code me calm Tim Smith all
right so it's starting to format up a
little bit and we can play around with
this you know we could do a little
formatting like that if we save this and
run it yeah that's looking a little bit
better we could oh I don't know we could
use tabs instead that is backslash T all
right there's a forward slash backslash
so this will tab everything over so if
we run this and now things are starting
to look a little bit better this one
didn't quite make it over because this
did tab but it
this name is so short the tab didn't go
as far that's kind of funny
we could do two tabs I suppose right and
here we could go outside of the loop we
could go name we need rotation marks
name yeah
plus two tabs and email like right and
here we can do print and one two three
four five plus couple of tabs and then
what one two three four five six seven
eight
a couple more oh I don't know
save this I'm just playing around at
this point cuz it's kind of fun alright
formatting has gone a little bit wonky
here this is too short but you get the
idea right you can sort of play around
with all this stuff let's get rid of one
of these tabs see how that looks
there the screen real quick alright so
looking a little better the point is you
can use all the sort of pythonic things
you want loops things like that to
format the stuff that you fetched all in
any way you want and you use it just by
calling any list item and returned data
so a little bit much to swallow in this
one but really pretty simple when you
get right down to it all this stuff at
the end which is playing around here so
that's how you sort of format results
using Python in sequel I three
okay in this video I want to talk about
primary keys and a primary key is a
database thing if you're familiar with
other databases you're probably already
aware what a primary key is and
basically it's a unique ID number that
each record in your database gets so for
instance we've got we've select
everything from our date of database
table customers and we've put it into
this items variable now we could print
out items right if we save this and run
it there you go we see each of these
items John elder 10 blah blah blah we
can like we did in the last video a
couple of videos instead we can go for
item in items print item if we save this
it looks a little bit nicer right so
each of these is a record this is a
record this is a record this is a record
right and you know each record has a
column first name a column last name
column email well actually sequel 8-3
creates another column sort of in the
background with a specific primary key a
unique ID there is unique for each of
these records and to see what that is
it's called a row ID and we can actually
select right up here in our select
statement we could just go row ID and
everything from customers now if we save
this and run it it's gonna print out
that ID as well so you can see 1 2 3 4 5
6 John - Tim 3 Mary so you know we can
look up Mary Brown or we can look up
number 3 right and we'll look at how to
call specific things from our database
in the next video but in this video I
just wanted a really quickly touch base
on that primary key because it's an
important database concept and in most
databases you have to create the primary
key to yourself and then create some
sort of auto incrementing mechanism
so that anytime you add a new record to
the database it auto increments a new ID
so for instance we have six right six is
our last ID if we added a new person and
we would need to create something that
said okay the last one was six so make
the next one seven right we don't have
to do any of that with sequel Lite it
does it for us automatically unless you
specifically tell it not to and I'm not
even gonna get into showing you how to
do that because you're never not gonna
want to do that you're always gonna want
this ID it's a good idea to have a
unique number for each record that you
can reference and we'll see why a little
bit later on in the course so I just
really quickly wanted to show you that
row ID it's just sort of unique sequel
like three three thing it does it for
you it's very very cool and yeah so
that's all for this video and the next
video will look at pulling out specific
things from our database like searching
for specific things and that'll be in
the next video
okay up until now we've just been
pulling everything from the database
from the table now we want to look at
how to pull off specific things how to
search for things right so you maybe
don't want everybody you might want just
everybody with the name last name elder
how would you do that well come up to
our query here and so we want to let's
get rid of the row ID we don't really
need that when I select everything from
customers and now we just use the where
clause where this is just basic sequel
where and we could go last underscore
name equals and use single quotation
marks elder right so if we save this and
run it let's clear the screen here we
get boom John elder that's cool now we
can also use all of our other sort of
comparison operators right if we had
numbers we could use less than equal to
greater than greater than or equal to
you know where let's say if we had an
age column we don't but if we had an age
column where age is greater than let's
say we wanted everybody over the age of
21 right or equal to 21 it would do that
right so that's kind of cool one you're
gonna use a lot is like so we could go
where last underscore name is like and
then use quotation marks to sort of
search and we've got a bunch of Browns
so we could go where the name is sort of
like B R and then you put this what is
that the percentage sign yeah - sort of
like a wild-card where it starts with B
R and ends with whatever right so if we
save this and run it we get Mary Brown
and West Brown right so very very cool
we've got a
Chuco Tamizh right we could play around
with that where we go where email is
like and we can start out with this
percentage sign and then we can go Kota
me calm save this
I'm not sure why that turned purple like
that yeah but we get three returned
results let's look at this more let's go
let's get rid of this yeah it's just
gonna do that it looks like so okay so
there were three now we can test this
just to make sure that was correct right
and let's save this and just run it
again so we have one two three and
that's all
so that was correct so a pretty simple
way to search for different things using
your query using the where clause and
like I said you're going to use your
logical operators those are basically
you know like I said equal to less than
greater than less than or equal to
greater than or equal to like and that's
pretty cool so in the next video we'll
look at updating records making changes
once we've already put something in the
database and that'll be in the next
video
okay in this video we want to update
records so let's head over here let's
just put this stuff down and let's go
update records and it's pretty simple
pretty straightforward and we just go
see go see dot execute all right now
this is gonna actually be kind of long
so we're gonna use those doc strings
again one two three four five six all
right
and what we want to do is update and we
want to update our customers table right
now we want to set what do we want to
set well let's say we want to change the
first name of John elder to Bob elder
right so we want to set first-name equal
to Bob and then we're and let's go last
name equals elder right
and actually we want to wrap these in
single quotes there we go comeback that
time there we go
alright so we could go to this all
online but easier to break it apart like
that so this will work but it's probably
not the way you want to do it we'll talk
about that in just a second so let's go
ahead and we want to
commit this so we'll go see commit our
conduct commit right then we want to
select everything from our database and
print it all under the screen just to
make sure that the change got made right
so let's save this head back over here
and run it again and boom we get Bob
elder Tim Smith everything else is the
same and it looks like it's worked now
this isn't a good way to do it I mean it
works and this is the correct structure
and everything but you're not going to
want to make a change to a record based
on a last name because we could have a
bunch of elders in there and if we did
that this would change them all and we
don't want to necessarily do that right
so instead
we want to come down here and let's call
our row ID again let's save this and run
it
and now we see our row IDs what you
really want to do is use those row IDs
for this exact thing right we want we
don't want to update all the records
that have a last name elder we just want
to update record number one so instead
we want to do it that way so let's let's
go ahead and try that again and up here
we want to set the first name equal
let's change it back to John we're and
then we go row ID equals one all right
so if we save this and run this again
boom now it's John elder right so like
down here Brown we want to change Mary
Brown - Marty Brown right so she's
number three if instead we did Brown
that would throw off some problems right
so let's try that and just see what
happens so we want to go Marty we're a
last underscore name equals brown right
so if we save this and run it boom this
one is Marty Brown and this one is Marty
Brown see that's no good we can't have
that right so instead let's change it
back to Mary
and we can do that like this save this
and run it
that gets us part of the way now they're
both Mary Brown but we want number four
to be West Brown right instead of Mary
so we would come up here where row I D
equals four
all right
Wes Wes Wes yep four alright so then we
want to change it to Wes so we save this
let's clear the screen and run this one
more time we get number three meri Brown
number four West Brown now everything is
right in the world so important that you
use ID the row ID the primary key in
order to update things also to delete
things we'll look at that next you know
just very important otherwise you can
get into all kinds of problems like we
just saw and that's no good so that's
all for this video in the next video
we'll look at how to delete a record
okay in the last video we looked at
updating records in this video we want
to look at deleting and deleting is very
similar to updating is pretty simple we
just come over here and go seed execute
and then inside here we want to delete
from our customers table and just use
our where clause where and then what
well
our data is gone but the last row was
that Dan guy he was number six right and
let's get rid of him we had trouble with
the formatting because his name was too
small way back at the beginning of the
course so let's get rid of him so where
we go row ID equals six now you'll
notice I'm not wrapping this in
quotation marks because that would make
this a string and the row ID is a number
it's an integer so you can't use a
string when it's a number so I just sort
of keep that in mind and I think that's
pretty much it so if we save this I head
over here and run it again boom
number six Dan Pass is gone so that's
delete once you delete a thing it's gone
dan has been dropped from the table and
we delete things we call it dropping
from a table so he's been dropped he's
deleted he's gone and that's that he
can't come back so keep that in mind
when you delete something it's sort of
permanent so uh yeah just keep that in
mind though so that's all there is to
delete pretty simple and in the next
video we'll look at ordering
okay in this video I want to look at
ordering and ordering allows us to
return the results however we want all
right now we're just returning them by
default which is just in order one two
three four five right so we could order
by just about anything and well we'll
just go through and do some and you'll
see so let's see let's change this to
order by well in fact we can get rid of
this instead of query the database let's
go order by alright so same sort of
thing right we want to select row ID and
everything from customers and we just go
order by and then let's go row ID all
right so if we save this and run it
we're not really going to see anything
different here
right one two three four five because
default that's how things go a sending
from small to high
that's a sending or a a SC a sending
short for ace and ding right you can
also do descending de SC short for
descending alright and descending is
high to low so we can do that just by
changing this to de SC all right so if
we save this and run it
now see the first one listed is 5 4 3 2
1 right pretty cool you know you could
type in ASC here but the default is a
sending so you don't have to be explicit
right we could ordered by the last name
now that's going to be alphabetical from
low to high or from A to Z right so if
we save this and run it let's clear the
screen we get three four one five two
but you'll notice Brown B so a b c d e f
g h i j k l m n o p q r s and it's like
that so let's see that was a sending we
could do the opposite descending from z
down to a right let me save this and run
it we now have the s ke b and b and
let's see
know how they determine which of the
Browns go first since they're both the
same I would guess it's numerically but
we're descending so I don't know yeah
interesting
so that's order by relatively simple and
yeah not much to it in the next video
we'll look at and and or
okay in this video I want to look at and
and or and and and or allow us to sort
of extend the functionality of your
where clause so you know let's just come
right in here let's go where so and and
or allow you to add more conditions to
your where Clause basically just search
for more than one thing so let's look at
our data real quick so we've got two of
these Browns right so let's search for
we're last underscore name is like and
then let's go BR and then that remember
that percentage sign and write and we're
row ID well actually first let's just
run this by itself just to make sure
this works right so here when we get
Mary and Wes Brown now let's say we only
want Mary but we're not sure so we have
to search also so we could go
we're last name is like bra and row ID
equals three right so notice we have two
two conditions this condition and this
condition and both of those have to be
true in order for it to return something
right so if we save this and run it we
see welcome just Mary Brown number three
right we can also use or instead you go
or and in this case it's gonna return
two different results Mary and Wes why
well because this is a different logical
type of thing before we just wanted we
wanted and and means both or means
either or or right do this or do that
so this has to be true or this has to be
true and in our case up here the last
name has to start with B R or the number
is three well this one starts with B R
it's number is not three but it doesn't
both have to be only one has to be true
in order for it to return and in this
case BR is true for this one so it
returns Wes and Mary so a pretty simple
concept but very useful there are times
when you need to search for several
different things and I've just done two
things one two you can do as many as you
want just keep slapping on oars or or
you know you get it or you know email is
like something or you know and you can
just keep going and going going I don't
know why you would want to but there are
certain circumstances where you might
have a few things you want to search for
you could do that with the work if you
need all of them to be true use and and
simple in the next video we'll look at
limit
okay in the last video we looked at and
in or and this video I will want to look
at limiting so our little database only
has five records so you know we likely
would never want to limit the results
but in reality you might have a thousand
records ten thousand a hundred thousand
a million records two million records
you know you might only want to return a
certain number of results right so to do
that you use limit and it's very simple
you just type in limit and then the
number limit to right so here if we save
this we're selecting the row ID and
everything from customers limit - I
can't imagine you would guess what the
result will be for this but it limits it
to two results right so we have one in
two let's see if we can string along
some let's go
descending this is gonna throw an error
I think I'm not sure so I'm gonna run it
yeah so we gotta go you know order by
what row ID descending right that might
work
we actually have to put our limit at the
end in this case so from customers order
by row ID descending limit - I think
this will work now get sloppy so now we
have 5 & 4 the last 2 right yeah
I should mention all of these things
we're learning you can usually just
string along just by adding them to your
executing statement here all right so
sometimes they have to be in specific
order like we just saw just now order by
has to go first and then limit it at the
end if it doesn't work when you try
something try changing the order and it
probably will so you know pretty simple
limit three limit however many you want
and very cool
so that's limit just very simple not a
whole lot to it but I thought I would
mention it just in case you ever need
the limit and yeah so in the next video
I'll show you how to delete a table
okay so we've already looked at deleting
a record that's pretty straightforward
in this video I want to show you how to
delete an entire table so like I said a
couple videos ago when we talked about
deleting when you remove stuff from a
table you're dropping it from the table
from the database same thing with a
table you drop the table from the
database right so to do that we want to
see dot execute all right and we're
gonna need to commit that I'll just go
ahead and put that right there
now inside of here first you take a deep
breath and then you just dive in drop
table and then the name of the table
customers alright so if we save this it
will drop the table and then try and
I'll put everything from the table which
there shouldn't be anything in the table
so see how that goes and we get an error
no such table customers so that tells us
that the the table has been dropped it
has been deleted and like everything
else when you delete a thing it's gone
that table is gone it no longer exists
and that's it so drop table pretty
simple and yeah that's how that works so
I'm gonna rebuild the table after this
video and we're gonna play around with
this stuff some more and sort of build a
very basic database app that we can use
and we'll start to look at that in the
next video
okay in the last video we deleted our
table we dropped it I've gone ahead and
recreated it I put all the data back in
exactly as it was so we can continue to
use it in this video I want to start to
build out a little app and it takes sort
all the stuff we've learned up until now
and sort of uses it so we've at this
point we've learned all the basics for
sequel Lite 3 with Python and you know
we went through it really quickly but
there's not a whole lot - it's a very
simple database to use and it's one of
the nice things about it so from here on
out we're not going to do anything
revolutionary we're just going to build
a simple app that sort of makes all the
stuff we've done up until now a little
easier sort of splits it apart into a
couple of different files so it's easier
to read and should be a lot of fun it'll
help us reinforce the stuff we've
already learned and I don't know just be
kind of fun so I'm gonna start right off
the bat I'm gonna create a new file and
let's save this as I don't know our app
dot hi and the first thing we want to do
is import database and that's just this
file right here that we've been working
on throughout the whole course database
app hi we can import that into another
file so what we want to do here is take
all of this stuff and build it into
little functions Python functions that
we can then call from the other file so
we'll sort of abstract all the database
stuff away and just make everything a
lot cleaner so I'm gonna start out right
here I'm just gonna push all this stuff
down let's create a function and let's
go define and let's call let's call it
show all right and what we want to do
here is just show all the stuff in our
database right in our table so I'm going
to take all of this stuff and I'm just
gonna paste it inside of this function
and paste and same thing with this
and let's add these guys as well
indenting is important for functions
okay and so we get rid of that now these
two guys I think we need to put these in
each of our functions that we create
okay so I think that looks good right so
let's create a comment and let's call
queries go query West query the database
and return all records right so
connecting to the database creating a
cursor executing a command to show all
the stuff in there putting it into this
variable and then looping through that
variable and printing out each item onto
the screen and enclosing making our
commit in this case we don't actually
need to commit any things we're not
we're just querying we're not committing
so we'll probably take that out
eventually and then at the end we want
to close our connection so if we save
this and head back over here now if we
want to actually use that we just call
database dot show underscore all like
you would call any function we need to
put it in this database because the name
of the file here is database dot show
all which is the name of that function
right there and we're not passing
anything in because it doesn't require
us to all right so if we save this what
do we call this our app dot pi and if we
head back over here we can go python our
app dot pi if we run it boom it prints
out everything onto the screen very very
cool now likewise if we commented this
out and save this in ran it again
nothing's gonna happen so there's
nothing else going on in our our app pi
so and our database dot pi only has one
function now we're gonna spend the rest
of the course building out more
functions that we can think call but
that's a good way to get started I think
and the next video will go on and do the
next thing
okay so we've created a function to show
everything now let's create a function
to add a record to our databases so
let's call this define and let's call
add one right and here let's make a
comment that says add a new record to
the table all right so we need to pass
in the stuff that we want to add to the
table so we want first let's call it
last and email right so we already know
how to add stuff to our database what we
do is well first we need these two guys
we need to create a connection and a
cursor and since these are inside
functions you need to do it every time
connect to the database and create
cursor just get rid of this there we go
right next we go see execute as we
already know how to do and we want to
insert into and our table is customers
and the values are we want to put
placeholders learn how to do that
already
alright now to add the variables that we
passed first last and email we just put
them right here first last email okay
and then we need to commit this and
close our connection right underneath
there boom commit our command close our
connection all right that looks pretty
good so if we save this and head back
over to our app now to run this guy we
just called database dot
one we call it add one let's make sure
here add one yep and we need to pass it
three things a first name a last name
and an email so let's go oops wrong one
here let's go well first name last name
and email we might go who me name here
Laura Smith Laura at smith.com
right so this will run that and then if
we want to show it all we'll keep this
one here just to to make sure so let's
go add a record to the database here
let's go show all the records all right
so if you save this and run it boom we
see Laura Smith Laura Smith calm has
been added very cool very easy and
that's all there is to it in the next
video we will create a function to
delete a record from our database
okay the last video we added a new
record to the table in this video we
want to create a function that deletes a
record from the table and this was a
little bit trickier than you might
expect and I'll show you what I'm
talking about in just a second so let's
head over here to our database table pi
file and let's create a delete one
function and we want to pass in ID now
inside of here again we're gonna make
our connections here and we want to
close our connections here
and inside of here we want to see
execute alright and we know how to do
this already we want to delete delete'
from customers where and we want to
let's do row ID equals and here we want
to put a placeholder alright and then we
want to pass in this ID which is this ID
right so that looks pretty good
okay so that'll work but now hit it back
over to our app to use this thing we
call database dot what do we call this
remove delete one copy this delete one
and now we want to pass in the number of
the ID we want to delete in this case we
want to delete six it's not up anymore
but six was the one we just added in the
last video now here's the weird thing
the IDs are numbers right integers we
know they're integers the database knows
they're integers so you would think we
would pass an integer but if we do we
save this and run it we get an error
it says module database has no attribute
delete one wait that's the wrong error
database delete one did we not save
let's backup delete one must not have
saved it alright so let's clear the
screen run this again alright this is
the different this is the the error I
thought we would get value error
parameters are of unsupported type for
this ID
we're passing a number an integer for
some reason we can't do that we need to
pass this six as a string so let's go
delete record use row ID as string right
so now if we save this in quotation
marks it'll pass this six over to here
ID become six a string it gets put into
there that then somehow magically
becomes a number again and it should
work it's the weirdest thing if we run
it boom now it works six has been
deleted and just that simple so that's
how you delete stuff in the next video I
think we already looked at how to add
one record let's create one to add a
bunch of records all at once and we'll
look at that in the next video
okay so in this video we want to create
a function to add many records to our
table we've already done one where we've
added one record so make sense that we
would do for many so let's go to find
add many and let's pass in a list we'll
just call it list and you can I'm just
gonna copy all of this stuff so
is execute many and then inserting a
customer's values but pop up
then here we want pass in list which is
this guy right here all right so look
good I think so
so let's save this and head back over
here and we don't want to delete
anything so here let's go add many
records all right so we want to call
database dot add many and we want to
pass in our stuff
no so here we need to define stuff we
need to create a list right and inside
of this let's add let's add two records
all right so here we want Bom Bom well
and I'm just gonna copy this and here
let's go Brenda Smith Orton no and she
is Brenda at Smith third ton calm and
here we'll call Joshua Raintree I don't
get these names Josh at Raintree calm
all right so we're gonna call add many
which is this guy we're gonna pass in
stuff which is all of this right
so stuff which is this list becomes list
and then here we just pass that in and
since we have execute many it should
work
I think fingers crossed
okay and then at the end we'll show all
so all right let's see if this work
let's clear the screen boom
so we have Brenda Smith Orton and Joshua
Raintree number 6 and number 7 and it
worked just that easy alright so that
was pretty cool a little bit more
complicated but still not too bad now we
sort of done all this stuff in this
program here and which I think you would
probably want to do as opposed to adding
it here somehow that makes sense right
yeah ok so that's all for this video in
the next video we'll look at where and
yeah that's about to the end of the
stuff but we need to add into as
functions so yeah look at that the next
video
okay so let's crank out one more of
these functions let's look at the where
clause now to create a function to deal
with where is kind of silly I mean
there's just so many options you could
look up you know pull all the records
for database where first-name is X or
where last name is X or where email
address is X or where you know row ID is
X or you know any of us zillion
different permutations of that so it
doesn't really make a lot of sense
to create a where function but we're not
really building a real app here we're
just sort of playing around with this to
reinforce some of the concepts so might
as well just knock one out and let's
just say we want to look up email
addresses it's pretty simple so let's
just call define email lookup and we
want to pass email
I guess all right so I'm just gonna copy
all of this paste it in and for our
execute what do we want to do we want to
select everything from customers right
where and we want where email equals and
we want to pass in email right now this
is a tough ball passing one thing and so
we put a little comma afterwards just a
little quirk and sort of how that goes
now we also we're not committing
anything here we're querying and we want
to put it up on the screen so we need to
come up here and let's see
like a with a query we need to fetch all
and let's loop through and print those
out so I'm just gonna copy that and that
looks good I think yeah okay so I think
that looks good right let's save this
and head back over to our app and look
up email address so we want to call
database dot email look up and we want
to pass something so let's pass John at
Kota me.com we know that's an address
that exists in our system so we mm head
back over here run this again whoo first
of all let's comment out this show all
one we don't need to show all we just
want to show the one that we're looking
up so save this run it Oh Oh Dan data
nice why didn't you tell me I misspelled
that database all right let's clear the
screen and run this again in boom John
elder John echo to me comm if we want
the ID as well so we would go just we
could add it like this row ID and
everything come back here and now we get
the row ID so you know you can do this
for anything you want if you want to let
you create an email look up one you
could do that if you wanted to create a
specific row ID you know primary key ID
lookup you could do that like I said
this app we're building here we have
built I suppose is you know this is not
supposed to be some professional app
we're building this is just a little toy
thing that we can sort of play around
with just to reinforce all of these
different things and it's kind of nice
to have this you know examples of how to
for instance query you know right there
how to add something to a table you know
right there how to add many things to a
table right there how to delete
something from a table it's just kind of
nice to have them all in one file and
you know for a reference going forward
into the future if you need to refer
back to this if you've built this with
with me along with me you'll have this
to sort of you know reference back so
it's kind of cool so I think that's all
for this video in the next video we'll
say a few more things and wrap this all
up okay so that's all for this video and
for the course if you liked it be sure
to smash the like button below subscribe
to the channel give me a thumbs up for
the YouTube algorithm I check out my
website coding me comm where you can use
coupon code camp you get 65% off
membership so you pay just $27 to access
all my courses over 40 courses hundreds
of videos and the PDFs of OMON
best-selling coding books join over
100,000 students learning to code just
like you my name is John elder from Kodu
be calm and we'll see in the next video